ان عمليات الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره في بعض
المواقع هناك بعض الحالات التي خرجت بعد
اكثر من 200 ساعه ودخلنا وكما وصفتها
بانها المعجزات طبعا هذه من ناحيه لكن من
ناحيه اخرى موضوع ازاله الركام بالفعل
العمليه ستبدا قريبا في معظم المناطق بعد
الانتهاء بشكل كامل من عمليات البحث
والانقاذ حيث ان رئيس التركي كان قد تعهد
يوم امس بان
حكومه الحكومه التركيه ستبدا ببناء اكثر
من 30 الف وحده سكنيه مطلع مارس القادم
يعني بعد ايام قليله وبالتالي فان عمليه
ازاله الركام ستبدا خلال وقت قصير جدا هذه
من جهه من جهه اخرى كما تشاهدين نحن هنا
في بلده نوردا في ولايه غازي عنتاب
التركيه هذه البلده تحولت الى بلده مخيم
بالكامل
هذه منطقه كامله
للمخيمات التي
يسكن فيها سكان نوردا هذه المدينه التي
تدمرت بالكامل تقريبا حيث اتى
الزلزال على معظم البيوت فانهارت وايضا ما
عدا عشرات الابنيه المتصدعه غير صالحه
للسكن هناك اقاويل ان الحكومه ستهدم هذه
المدينه بالكامل وتعيد بناءها بشكل جديد